in this video we're going to see if we
can compute what 3 divided by 0.75 is
equal to and I'll give you a little bit
of a hint before I tell you to pause the
video so let's imagine 3 wholes right
over here and what if we were to think
of these three wholes these three ones
and what if we were to think about them
in terms of hundredths well then we
could once we express these as
hundredths we could say well how many
groups of 75 hundredths can we divide
this into how many equal groups of 75
hundredths and to help you think about
that here's a little bit of a
visualization where 3 is divided into
equal groups of 75 hundredths so pause
this video and use what I have this
little visual here as a big hint to
figure out what 3 divided by 75
hundredths is alright now let's do it
together so as I said we started with
three ones or three wholes however you
want to think about it and you could
divide division by 75 hundredths as
saying well how many equal groups of 75
hundredths can you divide these three
holes into and so we thought about these
three wholes in terms of hundredths and
the way it's been color-coded it
actually has already been divided into
four equal groups of seventy-five
hundredths you can count these so this
is 10 20 30 40 50 60 70 and then five
hundredths so this right over here this
is one group of seventy-five hundredths
and then in green you have another group
of seventy-five hundredths so you have
10 20 30 40 50 60 70 and then 75 so that
right over let me just a color I can see
this right over here is our second group
this is our first group right over there
and then that's our third group these
are all equal
of 75 hundreds and that's some our
fourth equal group of 75 hundreds in the
green again so how many equal groups of
75 hundreds
can you divide three holes into well
clearly it is equal to four